supongamos que tienes una matriz de n
por n elementos que se mira algo así
tienes en la primera columna el primer
elemento de la primera columna es 1 y el
resto de los elementos en la columna son
ceros entonces tienes 10 y 000 hasta
llegar al enésimo término que también es
0 ahora en la en la segunda columna
tienes 0 en la primera entrada después 1
y el resto de los elementos hasta llegar
al enésimo término son ceros ahora la
tercera columna tiene cero en la primera
entrada
aquí 0 en la segunda entrada cero
después uno y el resto ceros como puedes
ver esta esta matriz consiste en unos en
la diagonal principal ajá si llegas a la
enésima columna tendrás ceros desde la
primera entrada hasta la n menos una
entrada y en la enésima entrada tendrás
el 1 así que esta matriz tiene unos en
la diagonal principal y eso eso hace que
esta matriz tenga propiedades bastante
interesantes las cuales
ya veremos en el futuro pero tiene una
en especial relacionada con
transformaciones lineales y también
tiene nombre tiene nombre tiene el
nombre de esta matriz es la matriz
identidad que se denota de esta manera y
sub n porque es una matriz de n por n y
sub dos por ejemplo se mirarían así con
12 en la diagonal principal y los otros
elementos ceros y sub 3 sería sería 1 0
0 0 1 0 0 0 1 y creo que ya tienes la
idea de lo que hablo ahora bien lo
curioso de esta matriz identidad la
matriz identidad es que cuando la
multiplicamos por cualquier vector es
decir podemos multiplicar esta matriz
por un vector por un elemento de rn así
que hagámoslo hagamos lo que tenemos el
vector con componentes x 1 x 2 hasta x l
qué va a pasar cuando lo multiplicamos
por esta matriz entonces tenemos que
este es el vector xy estamos
multiplicando a la matriz identidad y
sub n multiplicada por el vector x donde
el vector x pertenece a rn tiene n
componentes que voy a obtener voy a
obtener 1 x x 10 x x 20 x hasta x en es
cierto entonces lo que estamos haciendo
es producto punto de la primera fila con
el vector xy quedará de esta forma lo
haré como sigue a ok entonces vas a
obtener otro vector en rn donde el
primer elemento
es esta fila producto punto el vector x
entonces solamente va a quedar x 1 ajá
luego para la segunda entrada será será
lo que obtengamos del producto punto de
la segunda fila con el vector x entonces
0 por x 1 + 1 por x 2 + hasta 0 x x n
entonces ahí simplemente va a quedar x 2
y si seguimos haciendo esto obtendremos
x 3 x 4 hasta llegar a x n ahora bien si
tú observas a este nuevo vector a que es
igual lo impresionante de la matriz
identidad es que cuando la multiplicas
por cualquier vector te da el mismo
vector entonces la matriz identidad
multiplicada por cualquier vector en rn
de hecho eso sí se define para vectores
en el relleno solamente es igual a ese
vector ahora otra otra cosa importante
otra cosa importante las columnas de la
matriz identidad estas columnas ajá la
primera columna la segunda columna todas
las columnas de la matriz identidad
y este conjunto tiene nombre si llamamos
a la primera columna 1 a la segunda
columna la llamamos sub 2 a la tercera
columna la llamamos sub 3 entonces el
sub 12 sub 3 hasta llegar a eso en este
conjunto tiene nombre el conjunto de 12
hasta llegar a n
este conjunto se le llama se le llama la
base estándar para rn esta es la base
estándar para rn ahora tenemos la
palabra base ahí así que dos cosas deben
cumplirse 1 que estas columnas deben ser
linealmente independientes y deben
generar a rn la independencia lineal
tenemos aquí este 1 por ejemplo y vale
para cada uno de los unos en la en todas
las entradas no pueden ser construidos a
partir de él de los otros elementos como
combinación lineal así que es
linealmente independiente y ahora para
ver qué genera es decir que puedes
construir cualquier vector como una
combinación lineal de estos simplemente
debe
debes ver que cualquier vector que
quieras construir por ejemplo digamos lo
voy a poner de esta manera entonces si
quieres construir este vector el x no de
hecho no porque eso ya lo hicimos
entonces voy a poner este otro tenemos
el vector a1 a2 a3 hasta a en es un
elemento de rn que quieres construir
entonces lo que haces es ver que la
combinación lineal que te dará al vector
a1 a2 hasta en es literalmente a uno por
uno más a dos por dos más hasta n por n
ajá lo que lo que estamos haciendo es es
multiplicar este escalar por la primera
columna y el segundo escalar por la
segunda columna lo que te va a quedar es
a uno y después puro ceros más
0 a 2 y después puro ceros más hasta
puro 00 hasta n menos 1 elementos y
después a n los sumas y obtienes al
vector original este vector y es un poco
obvio no crees porque observa que esto
es lo mismo que multiplicar a nuestra
matriz identidad y suben por el vector n
ahora vamos a aplicar lo que ya sabemos
sobre transformaciones lineales y lo que
acabamos de aprender sobre la matriz
identidad yo dije que puedo representar
a cualquier vector de esta manera
entonces lo voy a escribir en términos
de x
yo puedo escribir a cualquiera cualquier
factor x como una combinación lineal de
los elementos de la base estándar
entonces x es igual
x 1 x 1 x 1 + x2 x 2 más hasta x cnn
solo solo recuerda que cada uno de estos
vectores columnas por ejemplo en uno
tiene 1 en la primera entrada y el resto
son ceros y 2 tiene 1 en la segunda
entrada y el resto de los elementos son
0 cn tendría 1 en la enésima entrada y
el resto ceros ok ahora bueno ya con eso
continuemos sabemos por definición que
una transformación lineal de digamos el
vector x lo voy a poner de esta manera
entonces una transformación lineal de
nuestro sector de nuestro vector x
entonces transformación lineal de x esto
es lo mismo que la transformación lineal
de todo esto entonces que era
transformación lineal de x 1 1 + x 12 2
de hecho lo voy a escribir de la otra
forma porque esta no es la anotación que
que se usa usualmente entonces
así que escribo la transformación lineal
del vector x es igual a la
transformación lineal de todo esto sería
x 11 + x 22 más hasta x n
en esto son equivalentes ahora por
definición de transformación lineal
sabemos que la transformación de la suma
es la suma de las transformaciones
bonito bonito juego de palabras me
encanta ahora esto entonces esto lo
mismo que la transformación de x 11 más
la transformación de x 2 2 + de hecho
también cabe mencionar que esto esto es
para cualquier transformación lineal lo
voy a escribir aquí cualquier
transformación
y aquí seguimos debe satisfacer estas
propiedades por ser transformación
lineal entonces tenemos la suma hasta la
transformación de x n
n y también sabemos por las propiedades
de transformación lineal que la
transformación lineal de un vector que
multiplica que multiplicado por un
escalar es igual al escalar que
multiplica la transformación lineal del
vector entonces por la definición esto
es igual a x1 que multiplica a tras la
transformación lineal de 1 + x2 que
multiplica la transformación lineal de 2
más hasta llegar a x en el aquí x n que
multiplica la transformación lineal de n
y que es esto
esto lo puedo escribir de la siguiente
manera la transformación lineal del
vector x es igual ya sabemos que sabemos
que una transformación lineal deben
cumplirse dos cosas en una
transformación lineal una que la
transformación de la suma es la suma de
las transforma
y que saca escalares entonces si vemos a
esto como vector columna esto es igual
esto es igual a la matriz donde la
primera columna es la transformación de
e1 la segunda columna será la
transformación de 2 y así hasta llegar a
la transformación a la enésima columna
que será la transformación de n esto
multiplicado por el vector el vector x 1
x 2 hasta x n y ya hemos hecho esto
antes iniciamos recuerda iniciamos con
una transformación lineal arbitraria y
acabo de mostrar que una transformación
lineal arbitraria de x puede ser escrita
como el producto de una matriz donde yo
tomo la misma transformación lineal de
cada uno de nuestros elementos en la
base estándar y la multiplicó por el
vector x esencialmente lo que estoy
haciendo estoy estoy probando que todas
las transformaciones lineales pueden ser
el producto de una matriz con un vector
entonces lo escribo todas las
transformaciones todas las
transformaciones
reales pueden ser el producto el
producto de una matriz con un vector y
de hecho esto es algo es algo bastante
común y está sencillo y verás es una
operación bastante sencilla te voy a dar
un ejemplo de hecho para mí a mí se me
hace algo elegante sencillo y te va a
gustar así que voy a intentar me alguna
transformación lineal digamos que tengo
una transformación que va de r2 r3 y
vamos a vamos a definirla de la
siguiente manera entonces las
transformaciones tal que para un vector
x 1 x 2 es igual a x 1 + 3 x 2 en la
segunda entrada 5 x 2 menos x 1 y en la
tercera entrada 4 x 1 + x 2 así vamos a
definir esta transformación y también
puede describirse a la siguiente manera
de cualquier vector en r2 es igual
la matriz así x 1 + 3 x 2 5 x 2 - x 1 y
4 x 1 + x 2 son dos formas distintas de
escribir lo mismo me gusta más la
segunda ahora entonces bueno te acabo de
decir que que puedo representar a esta
transformación como el producto de de
una matriz con un vector entonces cómo
hago eso lo que hago es tomar es tomar
la transformación de él de esto observa
observa aquí aquí tenemos que el dominio
es r 2 y bajo la transformación llegamos
al vector a un vector en r3 lo que
haremos es iniciar con la matriz
identidad y sub 2 en este caso baja
porque ese es nuestro dominio entonces y
sub dos es igual a 1 0 y 0 1 inició con
esto y aplicó la transformación lineal a
cada columna a la base estándar porque
observa que esos son los elementos de la
base estándar de r2 cierto 1 0 y 0 1
entonces ahí tenemos a los elementos
base estándar para r2 pero por qué se le
llama base estándar sucede que cuando
cuando tú tomas el producto punto con
cualquiera de ellos cualquier elemento
entre ellos siempre son ortogonales ajá
el producto punto entre ellos es siempre
0 y también tienen longitud 1 esa es una
razón por la cual se le llama base
estándar pero en fin a vamos a regresar
aquí ya no sólo a nuestro intento por
representar a esta transformación como
el producto como una matriz vector
columna entonces decimos qué bueno vemos
que nuestro nuestro dominio sr2
iniciamos entonces con y sub 2 nuestra
matriz identidad de 2 por 2 y aplicamos
la transformación a cada a cada vector
columna baja los cuales pertenecen a la
base estándar
son los elementos de la base estándar
para r 2 entonces lo que haré es
escribirlo así la primera columna será
la transformación de 10 y la segunda
columna será la transformación de 0 1
entonces
aquí 01 ahora bien que es la
transformación a que es igual a
transformación de 10 simplemente observa
cómo se define la transformación lineal
como la definimos entonces la
transformación de 10 es igual a 1 + 3
por 0 eso es igual a 1 aquí va uno en la
segunda entrada será 5 por 0 menos uno
es igual a menos uno y la tercera
entrada 4 por 10 es igual a 4 entonces 4
aquí eso es la transformación para 10
ahora vamos que es la transformación de
0 1 la transformación de del vector 0 1
esto es igual a cero más 3 x 1 es igual
a 3 en la primera entrada
en la segunda entrada tenemos 0 menos 1
es igual a menos 1 menos uno porque no
espera aquí estoy mal porque estoy mal
estoy mal
me estoy equivocando tenemos aquí 5 x x
2 pero x2 es igual a 1 no es igual a 0
entonces borro esto voy a borrar esto y
tenemos entonces 5 x x 2 donde quizás es
igual a 1 tenemos 5 x 1 - 0 es igual a 5
y 4 x 0 +1 es igual a 1 entonces lo que
acabo de mostrarte es que si yo aplico
la transformación lineal a cada uno de
los vectores en la base estándar que
obtengo que obtengo obtengo este nuevo
vector veamos si yo tomo al primer el
primer vector 10 y le aplicó la
transformación lineal obtengo uno menos
1 y 4 y para el segundo vector 01
obtengo 3 5 y 1 y lo que acabo de hacer
bueno de hecho es algo que me parece me
parece algo bastante fascinante
podemos ahora reescribir esta
transformación como el producto de
cualquier vector
sí sí ok si esto si esto es a si esto es
a no de hecho mejor lo voy a hacer de
esa otra forma entonces podemos escribir
nuestra transformación de x1 x2 puede
ser escrito como el producto de esta
matriz la matriz la pongo aquí esta
matriz 13 menos 15 y 41 esta matriz
multiplicada por el vector x 1 x 2 x 1 x
2 y eso es realmente fascinante porque
porque ahora sólo debemos hacer esta
multiplicación de matrices no lo sé me
parece algo bastante elegante porque lo
que está pasando es que es que estamos
aplicando la transformación a las
columnas de la matriz de 2 por 2 y
obtenemos una matriz de 3 por 2 esta
matriz es de 3 por 2 que sabemos cuando
de la multiplicación de una matriz de 3
por 2 por un vector de r2 también este
vector puedes verlo como una matriz de 2
por 1
tenemos te dará como resultado un vector
en r3 entonces la primera fila por el
vector te dará el primer término la
segunda fila por el vector te dará el
segundo término y la tercera fila por el
vector te dará el tercer término
entonces al construir está esta matriz
de tres por dos al construirla también
hemos construido un mapeo de r2 r3 y lo
que me parece bueno no se me parece
bastante elegante e interesante y espero
también a ti te haya servido nos vemos